supongamos que tengo una transformación
lineal que va de rn en r
así que te es una función cuyo dominio
es rm y cuyo contra dominio también es r
si me dando un vector x en rn
entonces te lo transforma en otro vector
lrm
que no manda un vector que digamos
podemos denotar por
tx
es decir trx es la imagen de x bajo la
transformación t o lo que es lo mismo de
x es el resultado de aplicarle la
transformación t al vector x
ahora bien como t es lineal
como t es lineal nosotros hemos visto
tve keys es igual a una matriz a x el
vector x
de hecho decimos que a
es la matriz
la empresa asociada con la matriz de la
transformación
es la matriz a es la matriz de la
transformación t y eso sólo significa
que te dé x es igual a x x
ahora últimamente hemos visto que rn
tiene distintas bases y que por lo tanto
el vector x se puede expresar en
coordenadas con respecto a distintos
sistemas ordenados con respecto a
distintas bases así que tiene x es igual
a a de x si y sólo si no sólo cuando x
está expresada en coordenadas estándar
así que en realidad hay la matriz de la
transformación t
con respecto
respecto
la base
estándar de crm
vamos a hacer esto un poco más concreto
vamos a suponer
que tengo una base ve
un bebé es una base de rn así que ve
tiene n vectores
finalmente independientes b1 b2
si hasta
ven son n vectores linealmente
independientes
así que el vector bueno para empezar ve
como son n vectores linealmente
independientes en rn b es una base de es
una base
de o para
terreno
el vector x entonces se puede expresar
en coordenadas con respecto a la base b
podemos escribir las coordenadas con
respecto a la base b cuando simplemente
escribo x así solito simplemente estoy
refiriéndome a que x está en coordenadas
con respecto a la base estándar por eso
nunca usábamos esta parte porque siempre
que hablamos de vectores estaban
escritos en términos de la base estándar
pero si tenemos otra base p entonces
tengo que el vector x se puede expresar
en coordenadas con respecto a esa base
entonces como decía antes no le interesa
cómo está escrito el vector x no le
interesa cuál es el nombre por así
decirlo la imagen de t la imagen del
vector x bajo la función t simplemente
sería de nuevo trx pero ahora también
podríamos expresar atv x en coordenadas
con respecto a la base b
y en la imagen de este vector del vector
x con respecto a la base ve de nuevo
tiene que ser el mismo vector que estaba
siendo la imagen con respecto a la base
estándar
muy bien
si cuando estamos trabajando con la base
estándar existía esta matriz a que
multiplicada por el vector x me daba la
imagen en términos de la base estándar
con coordenadas en la base estándar es
lógico preguntarnos existe una matriz d
sistema triste
tal que de multiplicada por el vector x
en coordenadas con respecto a la base ve
si esto es lo mismo que directamente la
imagen del vector x
en coordenadas respecto a la base b
y una respuesta es que sí
vamos a analizar esto con un poquito más
de cuidado
antes que nada tenemos que recordar que
podemos definir algo que es la matriz de
cambio de base
se es la matriz de cambio de base para
la base b y lo que es es simplemente una
matriz cuyas columnas son precisamente
los miembros de mi base de uno de dos
así
hasta ve así que es una matriz de n
columnas
además como cada uno de estos vectores
está en rn
entonces estos vectores son de entradas
cada uno así que esto es una matriz de
gm por efe
y puedo decir algo aún más fuerte tengo
n vectores y n filas en renglones y bien
en el renglón de tiene columnas y además
las columnas son linealmente
independientes así que se es
invertible
invertir
además en el vídeo pasado vimos algunas
fórmulas interesantes
interesantes
si empiezo con mi vector con un vector
escrito en coordenadas respecto a la
base b lo multiplicó con una matriz
lo que tengo es el vector a pero en
términos de la base estándar
tengo simplemente el vector de nueva
cuenta y como esta matriz es invertible
puedo multiplicar esta ecuación por ser
la menos 1 por la izquierda
de ambos lados del igual entonces lo que
tendría ese al menos uno por su
identidad
multiplicada por el vector a ver las
coordenadas del vector
respecto a la base de ordenador de art
respecto a la base ve
y esto va a ser igual
al menos uno
por el vector
así que estas ecuaciones nos permiten
pasar de la base estándar a la base de
coordenadas respecto a la base b
y viceversa
con esto puedo reducir esto o cambiar
esto esta ecuación algo más útil
lo que tengo lo que tengo hasta ahora es
que
d
por multiplicar por el vector x respecto
a la base de la matriz de me debe dar lo
mismo
las coordenadas de la transformación de
la imagen de x bajo la transformación t
respecto a la base b
ahora yo sé quiénes son las coordenadas
de la imagen de x bajo la transformación
en términos de la base estándar
simplemente de x es igual a a por el
vector x así que esto es lo mismo que
las coordenadas respecto a la base b
de el vector a por equis
respecto a la base bien
entonces lo que tengo son las
coordenadas de un vector que más bien
tengo un vector en coordenadas estándar
y quiero encontrar sus coordenadas
respecto a la base b así que pulsar esta
ecuación esta segunda ecuación
y ésta
para escribir
esto es lo mismo que
sea la menos 1 y en este caso el vector
a es todo la matriz a por el vector x y
que sea la menos 1 x
por el vector x
bien vamos progresando ahora yo quiero
poner esto en términos de la base ve
quiero agarrar el vector en coordenadas
con respecto a la base ve y obtener su
imagen en coordenadas con respecto a la
base ve
así que ahora lo que tengo es el vector
x en coordenadas estándar y entonces si
lo que quiero es ponerlo en términos del
vector de coordenadas de el vector x en
términos de la base ve posar ahora la
primera ecuación y escribir
sea la menos uno
x
y x es lo mismo que sé
por el vector x el término de la base b
respecto a la base vea
y ahora simplemente asocio las matrices
juntas de al menos 1 hora
porsche multiplicada por el vector x en
coordenadas respecto a la base d
ahora el punto crítico aquí es que esto
se vale para cualquier vector x así que
lo que tiene que pasar que tiene que
pasar es que de hecho de sea igual o sea
la menos uno por a posee
y tiene que ser igual a la matriz de
cambio de base invertida al inverso de
la matriz de cambio de base por la
matriz a por la matriz c
y esto es lo que realmente aprendimos el
día de hoy
me escribo todo esto para que sincero en
una buena y ver qué es lo que está
pasando
vamos a decir
si de
es la matriz
beatriz de la transformación
formación
respecto
habíamos dicho que a era la matriz de la
transformación t con respecto a la base
estándar ahora lo que estamos buscando
es la transformación
la matriz de la transformación pero ya
no en términos de la base estándar sino
en términos de la base b
así que de es la matriz de la
transformación de respecto
la base
ve
además
tengo que si se es
la matriz
de cambio de base
cambio
base
la base ahora que va a ser activa se
quiero llegar a la base
para ver
y además lo último que voy a escribir
es la matriz
matriz de la transformación
nación
respecto a la base estándar esto en
realidad ya lo tenía allá arriba
pero es bueno repetirlo para que te
quede todo junto respecto a la base
base
estándar
entonces
entonces d
debe ser igual o sea la menos 1
la matriz inversa s multiplicada por la
matriz a multiplicada por la matriz 6 de
nuevo
y esta es la fórmula que nos permite
cambiar las matrices de las
transformaciones entre base y base
es decir
si lo que tengo es una transformación y
yo sé cómo se comporta respecto a la
base estándar lo que conozco de su
matriz respecto a la base estándar la
noticia de la transformación respecto a
la base estándar entonces puede escribir
la matriz de la transformación respecto
a cualquier otra base simplemente
escriba una matriz de cambio de base que
tiene por columnas a los vectores de la
nueva base
nueva base la invierto y sé que es
invertible precisamente porque como esto
es una base estos son linealmente
independientes
así que invierto esa matriz
la multiplicó por la matriz original la
matriz de la transformación t respecto a
la base espalda y la vuelvo a
multiplicar por la matriz de cardio de
base y así puedo pasar de la matriz con
respecto a la base estándar
en la matriz de la transformación con
respecto a cualquier otra base